this video will show you how to
construct an API that runs on the micro
gateway
here is a visual representation of the
architecture or topology that will be
used for this course you'll see that the
API management node at the very top is
actually running on bluemix in the cloud
the API developer or in other words you
is using a browser to access that API
management node the API management node
also connects to the API gateway which
in this particular case is the
standalone micro gateway this standalone
micro gateway will be running on the
developers local machine once that
gateway is up and running it can then
reach out onto the network to any sorts
of resources within the enterprise or
outside the enterprise that you directed
to get to note also that when it comes
time to let other people or other
developers know about your micro gateway
API you can use the developer portal we
will not use that particular step for
this course
this course assumes that you have
already installed the micro gateway on
the local developer workstation and that
you have configured your bluemix
environment to communicate with the
micro gateway to begin login to your
bluemix account from the dashboard click
the menu icon and then select drafts
once you arrive at drafts click on api's
then click Add and click create a new
API give the new API and name in this
particular case we're going to call it
our equipped
do not associate it with any product and
click Add when the new API comes up
you'll see that a number of
configuration items are already set we
will set the scheme as HTTP
this API will produce HTML output
you
right now we're going to remove the
security definition that can be added
again later when we on it now we create
a path and this will be the path that
external people call to take advantage
of the yoga API and this path because
lash we quote the standard operation is
a get and that will suffice for us we
have nothing else to add to this
relatively simple API now we click a
symbol
now we click invoke
and we give the invoke a title in this
particular case a brainy quote we now
set the URL that this invoke will invoke
to go and get the resource information
that this API represents in this
particular case we are going out to wbr
a Nico calm to get a hold of some brainy
quotes
in this case we are also going to append
a search term that will be embedded in
the request Cleary string so we use this
environment variable representation for
clearing string scrolling down for the
rest of the invoke configuration we see
they were not doing anything else beyond
the defaults
now we can actually click the test
button and this will allow us to create
a product first we select the micro
gateway apps catalog which is the
catalogue that points in our micro
gateway environment now we create a new
product called recoat and we go ahead
and associate the APN and create the
product
now notice that we haven't saved this
yet so we go up and save it and when we
do that the test environment notices
that it's no longer saved correctly so
we republish the product this sequence
of events will happen every time you
change the API and then want to go ahead
and test it okay now we go back to our
developer workstation we set our console
level debugging to debug and we restart
the gateway the Gateway goes out to the
API manager on bluemix obtains the
configuration for the new API which we
can then now use curl to actually invoke
our first API is actually up and running
and it works now let's have a look into
you what we really saw happening here if
we scroll back in the debug of the
console we can see here to where the
invoke took advantage of our query
string and went out and invoked for any
quote that is all very well and good
with one problem all of the links and
URLs embedded in the return from brainy
quote comm point to brainy quote calm
and not back to our ABI so let's fix the
fact that we want all URLs to point to
our API and not to the backend so we use
a Java Script that does exactly that
now we go back and retest our API we
republish it because it has changed and
we can reinvest we have to get the micro
gateway running on the developer
workstation to pickup the changes from
the micro gateway API manager so we stop
and restart the micro gateway once again
now we go over and run the curl command
to invoke the API in this case we're
looking for quotes from Shakespeare and
when we look at the response from the
API now we see that the links have been
replaced with our own links that point
back to our own API this API is now
ready
thank you for watching this video be
sure to visit the other two videos in
this series